as chair of the house ways and means
committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of covert 19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a revenue work session please
note that there are no physical location
for members of the public to observe
and listening contemporarily to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaries
during the meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all next necessary access information
has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules rsa
91-a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call 271
or email hcs leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting
assisting us christopher shea and
jennifer iv
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking the
roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with them during this
meeting
which is required under the right to
know law representative bernstein if you
take the role thank you mr chair good
morning everyone
let's start the roll call with
representative patrick abrami
air home and stratum my wife's in the
house house
senator mary griffin don't see mary
we we are trying to actively track her
down by the way
good representative owery
you're muted jordan
now there we go at home wife is in the
house
representative russ ober
i don't see russ russ ober
representative fred doucette
representative ducette representative
bershteen is your clerk and i'm in
beautiful nottingham new hampshire
in my home office representative robert
elliott
uh here in salem new hampshire and my
wife is in the house
representative john janigan here in
salem new hampshire and my wife and
daughter are in the house
representative herschel nunes good
morning i'm
home alone in pelham new hampshire
representative tim baxter
thank you representative i'm here alone
in my house representative walter
spillsbury
here at home in charlestown alone
representative paul tudor
here in northwood alone representative
susan allmey
here in my home in lebanon alone
representative richard
here and jeffrey in my home office alone
representative thomas southworth here in
dover
alone representative dennis malloy
uh thank you here in greenland home
alone
representative thomas schomburg
i'm in my truck uh heading back to a
moment
representative edith tucker i'm here
in randolph alone representative jenny
gomarlo
here in swansea husband in the house
representative tom laughman
representative laughman representative
amanda gorg
here in lee in my home office by myself
representative mary hacken phillips
morning i'm present this morning in my
office
at concord new hampshire and i am alone
here
representative james murphy good morning
here in hanover
my wife and daughter are in the house
representative norman major
here in plasto and my wife is in the
house
thank you everyone there are 20 of us
present four of us are not
uh norm yes um
fred i spoke to fred 15 minute fred who
said 15 minutes ago he'll be joining us
he he's
actually trying to reach out to mary
he lives the closest to her i hope
mary's okay yeah
um before we get started i just want to
go through some
scheduling
tomorrow on the 4th we're scheduled to
have public hearings
at nine o'clock and then on
tuesday the ninth was scheduled to have
a revenue work session virtually as
we have had starting at nine
and then the same and then on the tenth
we're scheduled to have regular ways and
means work session
virtually on all the bills that we
heard and uh we
may do be doing some exactly
uh the work sessions will be on the
bills that we
will hear tomorrow and the ones that we
heard on the 28th of january
on the 11th there's
public hearings on six or seven more
bills
on the 16th revenue work sessions
commencing at 9 8 9 a.m
the 17th is public hearings on the
remainder
of our initial house bills
on the 18th starting a nine o'clock
two-hour meeting with the governor's
budget director
and then followed that by
revenues starting at 11 o'clock
and finally on the tuesday the 23rd
revenue estimates starting at 9 o'clock
and that's a schedule for the future
any questions um
i've talked to i've talked to the
chief of staff aaron goulet about going
completely virtual for our
meetings because i haven't had
one positive feedback relative to the
hybrid
meeting that we had the other day
the complaint was that if you
weren't in the room you couldn't be
heard by the people
joining virtually and
what does that mean it means that you
know
we could be doing this for nothing
because if
committee members can't hear and the
public isn't going to be able to hear
i've heard from those that have done the
meetings completely virtual that they
don't seem to have a problem
with the voice
so i'm trying to get a ruling
from my leadership that we can do
tomorrow's meeting completely virtual
but i would recommend
um
well probably front but i will anyway
is that most of you that can
do it virtually because the
chances of being able to understand more
would be better i know that
commerce last week when they met
they only had two in the room the
chairman and others were
all virtual and they seem to seem to
work out
so uh hopefully i'll have
better news uh but
we have to have a hybrid meeting
tomorrow so i'll be there
i don't expect to have many others there
but do what you think is right
any questions
what we plan on doing is
when we do meet tomorrow
norm i do have my hand up okay i wasn't
looking at the hands yet
but uh go ahead tom um i appreciate the
schedule way ahead the work sessions
generally go from nine to twelve
do you expect them also to go a certain
amount of time in the afternoon
just need it okay but it's probably not
like it's gonna go to a three or
something like that
it depends on you guys oh okay but where
you have so many work schedules planned
out yeah
okay now on those work schedules what's
also going to happen
is that we're making arrangements to um
have um
somebody that um representative
suggested he gave us three names of
representing from the medical to talk
about
the vaccine and the cholera about
19. what's that about covert 19.
yes and then what's the possibility that
things are going to improve
or get worse and what do they think
we need to understand that will
greatly affect what we think revenues
are going to do
so i'm working to make that part of the
work sessions
also was one of the
main areas i can't remember right now
represent major this is chris um
so i reached out to dr chan through john
williams at
department of health and human services
this morning to try to arrange a time
for him to come talk to the committee
about the pandemic and the vaccinations
and everything else that you may have
questions about
i've also reached out to the restaurant
and lodging
association that's it i have not heard
back from either one of those yet but
once i do i'm trying to schedule them on
those days that you just mentioned that
you would be doing work
the 9th 16th or the 18th after the
governor's budget director comes in
so once i have confirmation i will let
the committee know so
what was brought up yesterday
uh suggestions on who we would like to
hear from we're working on that
to make that happen
in addition i was trying to get somebody
from the
federal reserve bank of boston to
present the economic update from
national new england
and new hampshire at our january
meetings
but there was a blackout
that they don't do that up
for curry from like the 8th of january
to the 28th
so i'm going to try to sneak them in on
one of these work sessions to get
an update on the uh what's happened
what they feel is happening
relative to the economy
nationally new england and new hampshire
and then what will
what they feel will happen if
we solve the
vaccine problem and things go well with
the vaccinations
and what do they feel will happen if it
doesn't go well
the vaccination or something else
happens so we need to
understand what those extremes might be
from from
say somebody from the federal reserve
bank of boston so
hopefully we'll we can work that in
before
we do our revenue estimates
on the 23rd
mr chairman yes oh are you saying we
would vote
on the 23rd and not on the 19th
because if we hear important information
on the 18th
that would be too late for us to really
absorb it
if we i purposely
put some time between what we heard
on the 18th which is on a thursday
to give us some time to do our own
research and be prepared on the 23rd
which is the following tuesday
oh thank you you hadn't mentioned the
23rd yet
you mentioned the 19th which is a friday
oh i'm sorry notes that you
had mentioned 23rd i don't think he said
anything for f
for friday the 19th did you he had 23rd
yeah i'm sorry i heard that
somehow the 23rd is a lot better
i've stayed away from mondays and
fridays
and only use those as a backup
and also be able to use those maybe as
caucuses
i'm planning to have a repub republic
republican caucus
this afternoon at four o'clock and i
just sent the email out hopefully
it got out okay
um because
one other thing that's related to this
to the revenues
yeah we have a house session on the 24th
and 25th that's my understanding
yes do we need to have a house
resolution ready for that
no okay just wanted to make sure no
i i need to work that out with ken
weiler
right okay i just want to make sure
your finance will get down to business
after the 17th after the governor
presents
his budget
the first blush will be the 23rd
and then anything happens after that
we'll come back and revisit those
so norm we will exact a number of bills
in time to make it into the 24th and
25th
oh yes what i plan to do is that
on
tomorrow when we have those other seven
public hearings if we have any free time
that is
hold on one second
i there's four bills
i want to exact and i've gone over these
with susan
and susan has gone over those with her
caucus and i've gone over those
my caucus but i'm going to go over again
today with my caucus
and it seems that both caucuses are
lined up on
four of the bills so we must get those
out we need to get the early bill out
which is 5 33.
so uh bear with me tomorrow
if we get an extra 15 minutes in between
herrings tomorrow would we do an exact
session
and then after the last pill we'll do
if we had an exec those four we'll work
on that
thank you and i may have missed it i
apologize but
what did someone say what's happening on
the 24th and 25th
20th well i mean where are we going and
all that
on the 24th and 23rd
[Music]
in our caucus they said be prepared
on the for a session on the 24th and
23rd
and they're trying to work out the
details okay
and so
i would expect that we will have a
caucus
we need to get the early bills out
i mean we will have a session we need to
get the early bills out
all right any any further questions
on this okay
then we will get into the
revenues starting with liquor
chris is the chairman of the lecture
commissioner
and the chairman uh malika's on the line
as well as
tina demers the cfo is also available
um i can pull up the worksheet like i
did yesterday or i can just leave the
screen blank for the moment you can tell
me what you need
pull up the worksheet thank you okay
let's do that right now
and while he's pulling up the worksheet
you have the
handout that was presented to us
from the liquor commission
so you should see the worksheet now
yes and um column d
is the liquor revenue and column k
is the beer tax revenue
all right so commissioner it's all yours
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee joseph moloch i'm the chairman
of the liquor commission
with me as our cfo tina demirs
mr chairman uh what we've presented a
few days ago is the numbers that
that we are that we're comfortable with
our sales were strong in the month of
january due to a sale that we run that
includes all products
uh right at the moment our total
revenues
are up 4.7 or
4 million and our liquor revenue to plan
is up 5.3 or 4.1 million
but we are comfortable with the numbers
that we've proposed
and we don't expect to see any changes
moving forward toward the end of the
year
okay any questions from the committee
representative yeah
so when i look at hi hi uh uh
joe how you doing so listen
the target was uh 133.8
million that was the plan it looks like
you're still holding it
the rest of your coming in at 129 is
that what you're saying
that's correct even though even though
you think that the strength there
you won't be able to make up that ground
no well you'll notice that the transfer
to the alcohol fund is 18.5 million
so that's right that's that's up
230 percent or 11.5 million dollars so
you know it's that's the balance of of
where where the money ends up so right
but you're expecting a pretty robust
increase from that
uh was that that wasn't a one-time
transfer right this happening every year
every year we do five percent which is
the 10 million
and then this this past budget cycle
they added the new
uh law that allows for hhs to ask for
additional funds if the
granted advantage account is going to
fall short and that's the additional 8.5
they're asking for
this year okay so in your 136
136.6 136.3
it doesn't it does it
what does it anticipate it includes the
ten million dollars at five percent of
our gross profit from prior year it does
not include any additional funds that
they may need because that would be
based on
their quarterly review each year okay
all right
all right that makes you now that
reminded me what
why there's such a difference between
the 129 and 136
that there was an extra payment that had
to be made okay thank you
thank you senator james
oh thank you uh can you hear me
yes okay um just
uh the question is uh looking forward
to 202 and 23.
what are they can you speak to us about
the
risks the developments that might
get in the way of achieving those
numbers that you've got
as your estimate what are the what are
the downside risks
well we don't we don't foresee any
downside risk the market
the market is strong our sales are
strong
our brand is is doing well we're
we've closed some stores as you all know
and
consolidated others and are building six
new stores this year
so we don't foresee any risk in our
market
in our sales market in order to meet
those numbers
again those numbers pose
the five percent to uh transfer to hhs
so if hhs's
numbers expound beyond that
that will affect those numbers that you
see
and that's certainly a possibility
but as we've always said representative
our our job is to
is to make the money and bring the
profit in and where the money goes
is is the job of the
of the legislature so we always we just
do our best to make the funds and then
wherever the funds are allocated that's
that's certainly fine with us sir
okay well thank you you answered my
question
uh representative
thank you thank you mr chairman
on we we at them
at the moment we are selling to a
captive population that is stuck
in their second homes in new hampshire
and on working remotely and
it's conjectured on drinking and smoking
and doing a few other things like that
uh more than they used to um
do you are you assuming that once
dave a number of them have moved
back and we
have tourism running properly again
that we will uh we will just substitute
the tourism
for that and that we will be able to
continue to grow
grow the market well our
our numbers are are continually
representing that 50
of our 50 51 of our business
is cross-border sales and that has not
changed
during the pandemic uh we've seen a
slight
increase in in in-state sales and
obviously
uh the real estate market in the in the
state of new hampshire is very hot at
the moment
you're hard pressed to find a house on
the market for more than a few days so
we've certainly enjoyed that market and
people moving into the state
and a lot of those people are working
remotely from
wherever whatever state they came from
and
uh we're probably visiting our state as
tourists prior to that
so uh it really hasn't affected it
hasn't affected the balance of our
sales so we really don't uh we haven't
seen
what i would consider a tremendous spike
and we certainly don't intend to see
anything fall off given that our
cross-border sales have remained
consistent
thank you very much could you i was
trying to look at the previous
presentation
and you didn't do a chart that
explained the factors that that produced
your
revenue estimates in that at least i
couldn't find it
uh just now do we did we get given
something like that
on on slide five
we showed the breakdown of our revenue
categories and the growth
so this has our revenue from
liquor and wine our revenue from
beer and our other revenue and then if
you go to slide
six you can see that
we've shown with that revenue and our
expenses what our total net profit
equates to so we should be able to tell
it from slides five and
six when we can find slides five and six
i can't
do both pages at once when you're
sharing the screen i can't
can't split my screen
that is correct though the breakdown is
on five and six and it flows into
slide um eight and nine
where it shows you the breakdown of
what's being transferred to the general
fund to hhs
and what's being transferred for the
beer tax
okay thank you i would recommend
that you have a printed copy
with you when you're at these meetings
because they do have that type of
information the other thing on the
crossbar
border sales i live right on the board
in plaster and if you go by the liquor
store or any stores in plaster
the vast majority of licenses that you
see
are out of state primarily massachusetts
that so i i agree with the commission
that cross-border sales is still way up
um hold on one second i'm gonna
bring my my petition list back
up uh representative elneny
all set
yes i'll take my hand down on
on that's an awful lot of paper
that we're having to print out it's a
big job
too representative uh
romney followed by representative tudor
representative i mean yeah
commissioner um so when when the virus
started
what would you i think when you
testified uh you know maybe about nine
months ago
that the the phenomenon was that uh
store sales uh increased as restaurant
sales decreased
so as the as the far as the as the virus
diminishes
are you you anticipating that the
reverse will be true
that uh obviously restaurants as they
open now they're never going to open to
where they were in terms of the numbers
but
but you're expecting the reverse to be
true that
it'll kind of wash out that that more
more liquor will be consumed in a
restaurant and less at your stores
well representative what we've seen thus
far
is at the height of the pandemic
restaurant sales were off as much
as 45 to 50 percent
and and since that has declined
some at this point as of january 31st
2021 uh our on-premise partners were
only down
25.3 so we're already starting to see
uh that the revenues from that area
increase uh so we're we're very pleased
with that
obviously they're a very important part
of our business an important part of our
economy
so with that though our sales have
continued
to go up but we also feel that
you know given the sale that we run in
any particular month as i've just said
the past month is was a very popular
sale
and the sales will will trend up and now
when in february and march when we do
uh i don't want to say less popular
sales but sales of
less grandeur you'll see those sales
decline
as we come back into the spring you'll
see the sales increase again
so the the traffic remains consistent
uh the gross profit is strong because we
haven't run any gift card sales for the
year
but and we don't intend to run any at
least for this
upcoming uh fiscal year okay but it's
nice to see that our restaurant partners
are starting to gain
some ground back and people are feeling
comfortable and
and going out and that that attributes
to their growth
okay thank you thank you thank you
representative
representative thank you mr chair i'm
just curious if we have any visibility
into the 22 23 numbers that hhs
might want more than their five percent
that would give us a little downside on
these numbers if they come back in and
ask for more
those numbers are based off of the
quarterly review that they do
in the fund so we wouldn't know until
each of those years
and and at this point we don't know if
they're going to need more
when they do their next quarterly review
for this year right now they're
projecting that they need the 18.5 but
if if for some reasons their funds look
like they're going to be a little short
by the end of the year we could
potentially
have to transfer more
and obviously representative that's not
something that we're in control of
and as i've said we just earned the
funds here and
and the legislature spends them the way
they feel they need to
and we're very comfortable with that
system okay
representative are you all set i'm all
set thank you
any other questions from the committee
send none i want to thank the
commissioner and
[Music]
and tina
thank you very much mr chairman thanks
for the committee have a great day
thank you you too and we can move on to
the interest department and norma
stalin is here and i think it was
there's a new handout right of course
there is i sent it out last night remsa
major but i can put it up on my screen
if that's helpful for norma
why don't you do that and then they
the insurance department can walk us
through it um the commissioner
i believe is also in attendance
as well as um the deputy commissioner
rice and
amy duhain so they're all available to
answer any questions as we go through
the presentation so i'll share my screen
and then the
um insurance department can tell me
which slide they want me to move to at
what point
i'll just start off uh and say this is
chris nicholopoulos commissioner over
here at insurance
i'm joined with amy duhain who's our
premium tax
um administrator and norma stallings
who's our
compliance tax lead uh norm is going to
answer any questions and walk you
through but i wanted to attend in case
anyone had any questions for me thanks
norma you're on
norma you're still muted
sorry okay thank you very much
okay we're here today to uh
update you on what we're projecting for
fiscal year
2022 and 2023. i just thought initially
give you a little bit more background in
information as far as
what is actually taxable
the gross direct premiums which include
renewal premiums less dividends less
return premiums
is the primary source of the
taxable base direct premiums written on
stop loss reinsurance provided to
self-insurance groups
it's also taxable there are also
policy fees in membership and other fees
that may not be part of the premium
but are part of what the cost of the
insurance policy is
and they're also taxable policy
dividends apply to buy purchase life
insurance
which is additional paid up insurance is
taxable
and technically that is offset because
it's a policy
dividend so it's an in and out
of the calculation there are
other considerations and insurance
that will also be taxable
uh the insurance companies will
provide us with that information
medic aid premium is subject to
premium tax medicare
supplemental policies or known as
medigap policies which are sold by an
insurance company are subject to premium
tax
this is not to be confused with a medic
aid medicare advantage plan
okay so what's
tax exempt political
subdivisions so any further norma
you said not to be confused with the
uh medicare advantage
plans correct yes there there are
medicare medigap policies that are sold
that are not have not been
approved through the federal
uh center of medicare and medicaid
services so they
are not medicare advantage plans
so the medicare advantage plans tax and
not tax
medicare advantage plans are not taxed
which okay which is brought up on the
next slide here
so medicare advantage plans which are
sold
through insurance companies
are not taxable the other thing is the
political subdivisions
so if a county city
town or village purchases a
coverage of health or
dental through the
insurance companies there is no tax
associated with those policies
also medicare
part d which is the
pharmaceutical coverage that
is through the center of medicare
and medicaid services that's not subject
to premium tax
federal employee health benefit programs
are not subject to premium tax
servicemen's group life insurance
and federal crop insurance are not
subject to
premium tax so that's
the the com part of the components
in deriving what the tax base is
on this slide here is the fiscal year
2021 our current fiscal year
that we're in
in right now we had originally projected
130 million dollars and we had
subsequently changed that to 128.2
million
based on what was happening in the
markets
the automobile
insurance refunds in the
unemployment so if people were
not going to be covered by health
policies
and some of that was also a shift
to possibly these people being eligible
for medic aid
so currently and i think i jumped ahead
here it should say
as reported in december's revenue focus
we're currently 2 million dollars over
plan
and that's attributed to
the fees that are collected
for producer and adjusters licensing
fees
uh i really don't have an explanation
why there were a considerable
increase in the licensing
but there were a number of adjusters
and producers that newly licensed
in the last few few months
that were had not been licensed before
so and that's approximately one and a
half million
that's uh causing that increase
so now moving on to fiscal year 2022 and
2023.
again this is the summary of the
calculation the tax
premium tax liability
that is reduced by the
prepayment and then we receive
the estimated payment for the following
year
there's also the unlicensed or
non-admitted market
premium tax which we're coming down
to what we estimate to be the premium
tax
revenue and again we're
anticipating that it's going to be
a slow recovery the
businesses and even may not come
back to buy the insurance then there may
be further decreases in auto
so that's part of the components that
led us to believe that 2022
would be less and then we would have
an increase in premium tax for 2023
hoping that the economy rebounds
as an end result the current fiscal
estimate for fiscal year 2022 is
127 million and
2023 is 133.3 million
the next slide is the detail
of the computation this slide is
the actuaries information that is
provided to us
for the uh premium growth
patterns and they're coming up with
us by looking at what they're getting
for
tax rates i mean not tax rates for
the policy rates that they're approving
and also what they're seeing in the
market
so what ends up happening is the
premium tax growth rates for the
projections
let's take for instance for fiscal year
the property and casualty is anticipated
to grow
2.65 percent
on the next slide we have
the amount
that 2.65
is multiplied times the actual
property and casualty premium
of 2463.44
to come up with the 2 billion 528
72 in the next column so that's how
it rolls forward again the next column
is the growth rate
of 2.55
times the calculated rate
of 2528.72
the following year again we go back
to the growth rate of 2.55
multiply it times our 2
2 593.2
to derive it what the estimated
premium written for property casualty
will be and that's how this whole
schedule
works out you multiply
the growth rates times the
price starting off with what was the
actual
calendar year to come up with the
extrapolated
next calendar year so
for premium written in total we're
anticipating for fiscal year
2021 that it would be
6 billion 462.17
in again the the
columns just put down fiscal year 2022
6 billion 486 million 0.72
in the following year slight increase of
6 billion 628.27
on the next slide we have
the first line takes
the property and casualty lines
that are taxed at one and a quarter
percent
so we're simply taking one and a quarter
and multiplying it we've got
the premium tax is adding together the
four first four lines on slide eight
to come up with what the
premium tax net premium tax is
at one in a quarter and then
we add the as i mentioned what was
taxable was the finance
charges in any
of the other charges
that are assessed to come up with the
new tax base of
3 billion 158.8
and that's basically the information
going across the page for
the business lines that are taxed at
percent which are your accident and
health again
going back to slide eight in adding
the
medical and health lines of business at
two percent
in coming up with the
taxable and then we deduct
the tax-exempt part medicaid
medicare advantage medicare part d
the federal employee health benefits
to come up with what is the
taxable base at two percent
so after we've got the
on the next slide is actually the
calculations
where the
tax liability again we're taking the
prior information the
net taxable for property in
life multiplying that times one and a
quarter
and taking the medicare
the medical in health at two percent to
come up
with the 1.3
100 103 million point
eight and that's
how the the works all the way across
is that just multiplying the
net taxable premium times
the applicable new hampshire rate of
either one and a quarter or two percent
we also have the retaliatory tax rate
that is actually based on
what additional tax
is collected because i mentioned
in our other presentation there is a
retaliatory provision
which allows us to collect
the greater of the tax rate
that the company's state of domicile
charges
as opposed to what new hampshire charges
in that
amount is actually i look at the
last three years average
in the last five years average and
estimate it based on what i see the
trend
going so that's merely a
estimate based on what the
prior year's actual have been
the retaliatory items are
again when a
company is domiciled in
delaware for instance delaware has a
fraud fee
so because delaware assesses that fraud
fee on a new hampshire company doing
business in delaware
new hampshire collects on
the delaware companies that are doing
business in new hampshire
that fraud fee in the
the purpose of that is again to equalize
the tax burden so
one state will have
an assessment that new hampshire doesn't
have
in new hampshire will retaliate
because again the new hampshire
companies are paying
that assessment in the company in the
state
that is assessing has the assessment
number i have a question okay
um the retaliatory tax
rate that is in percentage
the 9.4 the tax rate is isn't
what i'm doing there is i'm taking an
average of the three the most recent
three years in the most recent five
years
actual and calculated
in seeing which way the amounts are
trending
so that the average of 9.4
percent that would be the prior
actual information that i had
well the first column is for fiscal year
2020 that is actual
that was nine point
four nine million point four uh
but when i calculated out for fiscal
year
2021 i looked at
the 9.4 plus the
actual amounts for the other four years
prior
and there had been you know swings up
and down
so when i looked at it it looked
potentially
too decrease and again
what impacts the retaliatory tax rate is
when a a given company
will re-domicile to another state
for instance if a massachusetts company
redomiciles to wisconsin the
massachusetts rate
of 2.28 no longer applies
they are governed by the tax rates in
wisconsin
what i really want to get at it's not
where you have retaliatory tax rate it's
not the rate
it's the amount of money generated right
millions of dollars yes yes yeah because
when i saw that i said okay
he said oh wow yes yes okay i should
have clear
clarified that that it's not that it's
the
dollars collected it's a retaliatory
amount
collected
okay we got that
so now i come down to
mr chairman yes his hand up
and i may have a different question
representative romney
thank you mr chair uh great presentation
uh this is the most detail you've
ever seen over the years this is great
uh
something that we obviously couldn't
replicate um
so you've done your homework here but
it's all it's all really driven on the
premium tax growth rate
uh most of this uh and that and i must
want to double check it's both the
increase in the rates as well as the
number of policies correct when they
give you that growth rate it's both
yes yes and so we're relying on these
consultant
firm now who are these folks again
the actuaries in the department we have
the
chief property and casualty and we have
one uh life accident health no no i mean
i mean you said you we used some kind of
a firm that helped us
calculate the growth rates no no
they're they are department
employees okay okay okay
representative romney i'm i have to step
out for a minute
so if you take over okay
all right i'm upset um let me see who uh
represent me i think you have your hand
up too
thank you i just want to make sure you
are going to explain to us what
retaliatory item basis is aren't you
i don't remember ever seeing that one
sure
that's when the state
as i said for instance delaware has a
fraud fee
california has a fraud fee pennsylvania
has the fraud free
and since the
new hampshire companies that do business
in the other states
are charged those fraud fees
we are able to charge
the delaware pennsylvania
california companies the same
front fees
based on what the business they do in
new hampshire
we collect primarily from
the massachusetts companies
and the illinois companies that do
business in new hampshire
okay you all said repsome army
yes that's a new one thank you very much
okay so any other questions no no
i think we're set for the moment can
keep on you can keep on going okay
all right okay so that brings us
down to the tax liability before credits
the business enterprise tax credit
that the insurance companies pay
that is allowed as a credit against the
premium
tax and if there is
a life in health guarantee fund
class b assessment that applies
the companies that are assessed
are allowed to take that
over a five-year period as a credit
the community development finance
authority
a company that
uh donates or contributes to a given
project
they are allowed 75 of that contribution
as a credit against the premium tax
that brings us down to the tax liability
and from the tax liability we have
received
the estimated prepayment
that in the prior tax year to apply
so it's similar to any any business that
during the tax year they pay
an estimated payment uh we
actually collected all at tax season on
march
15th it's not a quarterly payment
as most companies would pay
so the net difference between
what the tax liability is and what their
credit is
we use the term it's the true up
of that tax year
now then based on what the tax liability
is
the there's a hundred percent estimated
payment
for the following year that comes
up there and
i'm incorrect because that does that
says proceeding and it should say
following year i'm sorry
and that's supposed to be based on what
the tax liability is
there's sometimes a cha little bit of a
change uh
on occasion because companies will
submit an additional payment
anticipating that their
tax liability the following year is
going to be greater
so with the
true up in the estimated payment
we come down to what our
licensed companies tax
cash that we anticipate to collect
the unlicensed or non-admitted market
again that is an estimated
number based on what the averages have
been
in the past three to five years
we come down to what the premium tax
revenue is
then we have various fees
the majority of the fees that are
collected are from the licensing
of insurance producers and adjusters
there are also the fees for the
licensing of the companies
there are filing fees there's also
the penalties and fines that are
assessed
that are included in the the fee
number
the following number is that transfer
for the granite advantage
trust which is
two percent of the what is the medicare
advantage premium
and that brings us down to what our cash
basis
is for the revenue
there is a slight adjustment
at the end of every fiscal year because
we're collecting
that estimated payment of
in the priory for the following year we
have to we can only recognize
as of june 30th half of that revenue
so there is a deferred revenue account
that accumulates that
deferred amount for accounting purposes
so i just like to you know let you know
because that number
the accrued basis is what finally
is the number that shows up on the
comprehensive
financial annual report
so i think now it's just if there are
any questions
or anything that you feel you
want to have clarification yes
representative has a question
if we could go back to that page again
how do you estimate what
the transfer is going to have to be the
granted advantage is it under current
law
we we have an estimated
go back to page slide eight
again this this number here after
at the next to the last line here
granite advantage health plans
so that's what we're anticipating what
the
premium on that uh
medic expansion would be
and it's that premium tax
that is transferred over to the
department of health and human services
to that
dedicated fund and is that
that estimate is based on what's written
in the law right now
yes okay thank you
because they keep changing it every
biennium
yes they do
so are there any other questions
i see norm is back so i'm going to turn
it back to norm
you know i have no idea what the
insurance
department would ever do without norma
oh i thank you you are so thorough and
we've always taken your numbers uh
a lot of confidence well i
i try i unfortunately am a very detailed
person so i like to share the
information that i have
i know you are and i'm
norm norm there's one more hand up uh i
just uh
well there was
phillips yes yes thank you
i just uh i think i figured it out but
when i look at page 10
or slide 10 of your presentation today
for fiscal year 21 i'm seeing that 127
million 960 number
and then when i look at the revenue
worksheet for column
f for fiscal year 21 i'm seeing the
range
different and i'm just trying to figure
out
um you know
why it's reported one way in one slide
and
then a different presentation is
reported in a different way
well the information that i reported on
slide five
was as presented to the house ways and
means for an update
whereas the information on
slide 10 is a little bit more with a
little bit more
updated information once we had
some adjustments to the actual for
calendar year 2019 which impacts fiscal
year 2020.
and again that would go back to your
previous statement about those insurance
company
payouts and the reasons why they were
reduced premium taxes
at the outset of your presentation today
the payouts would
which are you you're talking about the
pre estimated prepayments
normally i think she's referring to the
uh the auto
rep uh the auto rebates that we
experienced over the summer yeah
i think outside of your presentation you
you had seen some decline
right we made some adjustments and
but that impacted fiscal year 2021
and that was part part of the reason for
decreasing the original
from the original
great thank you very very good point
representative
yeah norm does that mean that chris is
chris going to update our sheet to that
new number
128 instead of google b
so just so i can confirm what norma
are you suggesting that for 21 it's
going to be 127.6 million
instead of the 128.2 million
that's their latest number
so norma just just so the committee
understands that your your most recent
number that they should base their
estimate on is on slide 10.
yeah in fiscal year 21 it would be 127.6
million
fiscal year 22 would be 127 million
and fiscal 23 would be 133.3 million
yes
okay uh yes that that that's that's
true based on what information that i
had at the time
yep i will tell you that
we are ahead of uh
schedule as far as what
the is being reported in the revenue
focus
reports
so just to clarify one more time are you
more comfortable
is the department more comfortable
suggesting you're going to be closer to
the
128.2 million that you show on slide
five
or do you think it's going to be closer
to the 127 million that's on slide 10
oh a good point
for the fiscal year 21 21
uh i would
go with the uh 128.2 million
okay okay
so i i think we're good then on the
worksheet
yeah thank you norma okay thank you
any other questions if not
thank you the insurance department for a
great presentation
thank you have a good day thank you guys
security revenues as chris as barry
glennon here
norm representative romney's trying to
ask some
uh uh fred has an update on mary she's
fine
oh good yeah i've been worried about her
fred you want to give it i see you're on
now she she was uh staying with a friend
um but i i saw her spoke to her she's
fine
okay good thanks fred
okay we'll go on to securities
and barry garner director security
bureau
is here i hope
chris isn't here he is he's ready to
speak when you're ready griffin major
can the committee hear me okay and
can you bring up the
worksheet chris
actually mr chair i have uh an updated
worksheet
okay all right then um bring that one up
oh i see okay if if you would allow me
to uh
share the screen
go right ahead all right and are you
able to view that
mr chair yes terrific
thank you members of the committee uh
for allowing me uh to present
this morning um a uh just a quick
quick update with respect to revenue
since we last
met when i last presented
as of uh december 31 of last year i
reported that we had revenues totaling
uh
2.282 million uh
but we didn't anticipate a considerable
increase in revenue for the month of
january and we did in fact
as anticipated receive
fees for broker and investment advisors
as you can see on the screen that amount
that came in was 14 million two hundred
and seventeen thousand
one hundred dollars so as you can see
for
uh 2021 in blue year to date through
january 31 uh broker dealer fees are now
at 15
million 947 084
we do project that we will complete the
fiscal year
at 16 million 750 for that particular
category
so that that represents the um
probably the number that most committee
members may have had a concern about
because
through through december 31 it just
seemed off
uh but we knew that revenue would be
coming in
so we are still on track about
projecting
41 million 250 for
fiscal year 2021 i would also
like to point out in terms of securities
registrations
if i may lower the screen here for you
right now it's just showing that six
hundred and one thousand dollars
however we receive the vast majority
of our mutual fund uh fees
uh which are due on may 1. and that will
be
that will create a significant influx of
revenue the number is still
questionable as far as how many mutual
fund companies
will renew but we are are comfortable
in projecting uh 24.5 million
in fees for uh securities registrations
which would totally bring us up to the
41 250.
um so those are the updated numbers mr
chair be happy to answer any questions
that the committee may have
yes one second i got to bring the
participant
list up uh representative
thank you mr chairman are you is your
system
able to receive all of these
electronically or are you dependent on
the usps which
has been having terrible problems yes
the
the vast majority of our revenues now
are received electronically
we have been working with mutual fund
companies
uh to make filings electronically it
used to be just hard copy checks
however we do have a means by which they
can transmit
uh the renewal for us or to us along
with the revenue
so it provides for timely receipt
of those monies thank you very much
further questions
so what you're saying is that for fiscal
you're estimating 41 million 250
000 that's correct
and uh it it potentially could be higher
depending upon mutual fund renewals
which we will see uh come may 1 and uh
we'll certainly be monitoring that
okay so that's
essentially what you gave us yes
further questions
and christopher i will provide you with
a copy of this uh after the meeting
thank you barry
okay i don't see any questions and or
thank you for
coming in and updating this information
could i just have a follow-up on my
previous question
on i believe that we usually
get the first category of fees the
dealer fee
broker dealer fees in in december but a
couple of times they've come in january
if you're electronic now why are they
still coming
late well the we're unfortunately we are
at the mercy of finra which is the
former nasd
they are the entity that will collect
the revenue
from the various broker dealers and
investment advisors
and remit it to us and oftentimes it's a
timing issue
i understand that the actual funds were
received in the treasury
on december 31 but did not necessarily
hit
until the first business day in january
so it really was just it was really a
matter of timing we we experienced that
and i received several calls too towards
the end of the year
uh calendar year uh inquiring as to
whether those funds will hit or not
uh so uh in this case here yes the
finra did remit them to the state on
1231 but they didn't hit our books until
the first business day in january
any further questions from the committee
i don't see any thank you for
coming in and providing this updated
information
thank you mr chairman so now we can go
to
lottery chris is charlie here
he's not he's not in the call yet um
rips a major
so he may be coming in closer to 10 30.
10 minutes away
um i spoke to him this morning uh norm
yeah so he knows you know he's going to
call around 10 30.
all right why don't we take a
five minute break
um
all right
okay
chris is charlie here
he's not yet remsa major i expect him
momentarily
okay um but i did get a response from
john williams regarding dr chan
and coming to the committee and
it's unsure at this time if he's going
to have the availability
um but john williams did indicate that
last friday there was a meeting
with the um house health
and human services and elderly affairs
committee i guess it was a two-hour
um meeting where they recorded dr chan's
presentation to them
and i will get a link and share that
with the committee because that may
address some of the questions
okay um the other thing that
john williams suggested if we can't get
a time with dr chan is if there's
specific questions from committee
members
we could compile them and send them over
to um
john williams and he would get responses
from dr chan and his group for the
committee
but we uh he is checking the
availability of dr chan but i guess
there's been significant requests on his
time to
present to various groups including the
legislature
um so he's having some challenges there
or
or if there's somebody else who would
have
some idea of
what's going on relative to the covert
and what's the worst case in the best
case scenario
and the timing of these
yep yeah no that was part of the um
request so i
i told them john i would follow up after
you guys are done meeting this morning
and just let him know what the response
was from the committee
yeah see if he has somebody else that he
could
will do okay
because i i'd like to have an interface
with the committee members and the
presenter
i indicated that to uh mr williams that
there may be questions that kind of
arise through the discussion that you're
not thinking of at this moment
and that if having somebody talk to the
committee may be the preferred method
right yeah and it just adds to that
i think that's get get the best we can
from dr chan
that's very important but uh
representative murphy
identified a couple of other people and
i think
you said representative major that you
were interested in pursuing that and i
think having
perspectives uh sort of a broader range
of perspectives would be good on this
um difficult issue all right you will at
least have the link to
uh chan's presentation but
we still want to have somebody to
present this
to us uh chris if i may um
there's two names that you might ask
them about
jose mercado m-e-r-c-a-d-o
and michael calderwood
both dh epidemiologists and they've been
giving talks as well so you might just
ask him about those two people okay
thank you
so we're working on it could i just
make a suggestion too in order to make
it more attractive i should think the
finance committee needs to listen to
this
too well once we maybe we can join
i'm i'm going to have i'm going to
invite the finance committee and there's
some of these things i'm going to invite
the
senate ways and means committee to
also
where it's virtual that
might as well it doesn't make we don't
have to worry about rooms
there are a lot of advantages aren't
there yes
it's really quite surprising whoever
would have thought that sitting in our
own house would be as interesting
it's working out better than i thought
it would yeah me too
and and no trouble hearing you at all
and
representative malloy uh really hit the
nail on the head
and he said by being home you have
access to all kinds of things
your records your files another
laptop et cetera supreme major
a minority opinion i think it's an
enormous disadvantage to freshmen
i think that's probably i i agree that's
why the freshmen no matter
do not feel silly do not feel stupid or
anything else
jump in and ask questions because
there's have your item there that you
can't question
and that's the way you really dig into
this stuff
by getting styling with the questions so
i
encourage you to do that
there's some major uh mr mcintyre is on
the call now so you can start with your
revenues related to lottery if you would
like right and does he have a
screen he wants to share
or mr chairman charlie mcintyre here for
the lottery
i have a bad connection so i may just go
to
um audio if that's okay
so good morning this is charlie mcintyre
for the lottery uh i had
presented to you a couple weeks ago
revenue estimates this year of 120
million dollars
and the next two years would be fiscal
year 22
of 125 million and fiscal year
23 of 127 million we anticipate
growth next year particularly in sports
betting and internet
we do not expect instant tickets to
continue their tremendous growth
which we have enjoyed over the last year
uh and
the out year sort of the second year of
the biennium i would anticipate
massachusetts chooses to have sports
betting
so i'd anticipate a slow down of
revenues there
obviously we're still subject to the
normal economic pressures
of gas prices uh and the like and the
general economy
but certainly that's it in a nutshell
i i think our revenues are pretty basic
and i'm happy to answer any questions
the committee may have
questions from committee members
representative baxter
thank you mr chair i couldn't hear what
you said there you said you expected
something to slow down
um what what like a ticket or something
no i'm sorry so certainly uh one thing
would be sports betting
i anticipate massachusetts will enact
sports betting in the next year
and we'll have it live by the second
year of our biennium
secondarily i would anticipate scratch
ticket sales which have enjoyed
tremendous growth this sketch
to slow down probably certainly next
year into the following year
uh not stop growth but certainly slow
down we're up 20
on scratch ticket sales which is
historic so
uh i never like to plan for historic
events
got it thank you
representative romney
hi charlie uh to uh just amplify that a
little bit for the committee
what percentage of sports betting is
coming from out of state or like for
massachusetts but out of state in
general
so so currently approximately 20 percent
of our mobile
activity is coming from out of state so
80 percent
give or take is coming from new
hampshire vermont and maine
and maine in vermont they're very small
one or two percent three percent
um of the mobile side of our retail
side the majority is coming from
massachusetts
and so the facilities at seabrook and
manchester to a lesser extent will be
financially impacted
we have things we plan on doing if
indeed that happens
and it depends on where those facilities
are located it certainly looks like the
facilities would be located
in everett which is a far distance from
our border thankfully
but if one were to be located in lowell
say that would be very different
follow up oh
so do you anticipate they're going to
have uh just like us they're going to
have mobile as well as
brick and mortar places correct i would
just make a lot of mobile
from what i've read from the press
reports
press reports it looks like the they
won't
have college sports which is certainly a
big
activity for us and as we go into march
it's actually the largest sports event
in the spring
the college basketball tournament and
college football is obviously big in the
fall
so we'll have a competitive advantage
there but
yes it's my anticipation they'll have
mobile as well as physical retail
locations
just to follow up again uh norm if you
don't mind
charlie you won't explain that to the
committee just
we have a few minutes here uh about the
sports
spending on colleges my recollection is
that there was some
blackouts though right for yeah for for
new hampshire
teams yes and so there's a current
blackout uh you're not allowed to bet on
a state of new hampshire team
whether that be unh or dartmouth for say
for example
the only exception would be is if
they're in another tournament
so for example if unh makes the college
basketball tournament
you're allowed to bet on the tournament
as a whole but you're not allowed to bet
on unh
individually and so that was in a
request from the colleges that they
asked for that we were happy to abide by
and you folks
obviously abided by that as well thank
you charlie
it represented all me
thank you mr chairman on about the
scratch tickets you say they're
they're not going to be growing are they
going to be falling again
once people can get out and about more
i don't think so certainly um it's been
growth for the last 10 years almost
unabated
so uh and that's in the gross dollar
terms and also in net dollar terms
but i would anticipate at some point it
just will be slowing
not so one of the things is though last
year our
profit was approximately 100 million and
this year it's approximately
our we're estimating 120 million dollars
so 20 million dollars increase in profit
is
well it's historic so i would anticipate
slowing and certainly this is us being
conservative
thank you further questions
uh representative ames
i'll rub some names down mute yourself
yeah i got it yeah you got it um yeah
charlie uh
i may have missed this but um
could you uh speak to
how other developments in massachusetts
particularly their big casinos
um are impacting or
might impact our revenues here
um and so i'm not talking about sports
betting
the future of sports betting in
massachusetts or
their lottery program but the casino
and you may have spoken to this and i
may have missed it if so
i'm sorry no no certainly uh thank you
for the question representative ames
um the impact that a casino the casino
in boston would have would be
really related to charitable gambling
side which for the purposes of revenues
to the state
is quite minor we only estimate three to
four million dollars profit for the
state from charitable gaming
it will impact the charities certainly
obviously with their
casinos closed because of kovid it
hasn't had quite the impact
and candidly because of the location of
the facility
in everett it being everett and it's
sort of inaccessibility as well as their
economic price point
it also hasn't had the same impact that
we expected meaning it's hard to get to
and really expensive while you're there
in contrast to
the facilities in new hampshire
up um
so what about the uh casino
in springfield uh which is
maybe too far away to be a big impact
and uh the
uh what do they call it uh uh
casino in um
central massachusetts yeah you certainly
that's a good good question we have seen
more activity we've seen more folks from
new hampshire drive to foxwoods and
mohegan sun
then we have seen go to everett the wind
facility
and the one in springfield and certainly
the one in plain ridge because
you know if you're driving to plane
ridge it's a couple hours you're going
to continue on to go to foxwoods
which is a much nicer facility and
certainly the
those two facilities in connecticut have
loyal customers and they
obviously reward customers and so i
think there's a still that
loyalty to those two facilities over and
above the facilities of massachusetts
more so than i anticipated when they
were first
proposed and they've been developed
interesting worth watching yeah no
question and certainly
there's another lawsuit pending about
another possible facility in
massachusetts uh there's
one more casino to be located and that
certainly is still an
influx and where that goes uh that would
be in the southeast
i think because exactly unless they
change their mind
unless they change the mind look for a
better location i mean my terror exists
if they put it somewhere like in lowell
that would be my absolute
worst our worst nightmare um but they
have not realized the revenues they
expected obviously
don't say that too loud charlie i won't
uh further questions
representative romney
questions uh let me ask you mr chair is
it uh appropriate for charlie to comment
on house bill 533 at this point since
we are my senses but probably not
because we're not
we're not in a hearing session i had a
conversation this morning
about one of the questions that was
asked and since we have him on the uh
zoom about was the question was
uh is the attorney general's office
aware of
uh the new model that he's proposing in
house bill 533
and i mean i can share his answer with
the committee tomorrow
uh or if you want to he said he's on the
phone and we have a few minutes
we could get it right directly from him
i don't know if it's violating anything
for him to do that
i would allow it this is a public
hearing and
we had we had a public hearing on that
we're going to be having another work
session coming up
in public hearing norm that's one of the
bills we're going to exact tomorrow
right yes so
are you saying it's okay or not okay
okay
charlie wants to respond
okay certainly i think the question was
had the attorney general's office been
notified of this proposed legislation
and the answer is yes our chief
compliance officer
uh is formerly the attorney general's
office and
talks to them regularly about all of our
activities including this and they were
aware of it
and they're not opposed to it right
absent major representative
bernstein first and then followed by
representative
thank you mr chair good morning charlie
morning
in your presentation from uh a week or
two ago
you you did have a bullet point about
the state of massachusetts in acting
sports betting
is is there any new information or is is
the pace of
uh your time frame of when it will be
enacted i guess my simple question is do
you still stand by the revenue estimates
for
2022 and 23 or is there new information
which is going to
uh adjust those estimates no
the revenue estimates are the ones that
i hadn't uh suggested
in that presentation and we'll still
stand by them it's just i don't
anticipate the same growth
that we would have realized had they not
been and i
like i said it's a guess right what a
legislature particularly massachusetts
will do
so um it's my guess but i would
anticipate them legalizing it
in this next legislative session their
their current one
and it being impact revenues not the
next fiscal year but the one thereafter
i don't anticipate a down year i just
don't expect the same growth we would
realize
right you do have some modest growth
we're going from 125 million to 127 and
a half
yeah and certainly that's related also
to the
i just i really am conservative
estimating revenues out two years
because
of what can happen in two years um you
know representative you know
sure perfectly understanding thanks
jeremy thank you
i represent all me thank you mr chairman
um charlie i've got two questions
actually that one of them
is relating to representative abrami's
about 533
does the ag's office do any enforcement
for you now
um they don't they don't they do reviews
for us and they'll do background checks
for us
um but they don't do any criminal
enforcement
no thank you and then the other
questions totally
unrelated to that on in the
massachusetts casinos i think that there
was some
set up that they were going to be doing
impact studies
of on the effect of the casinos
on the communities et cetera on have
they
finished any about plain ridge for
instance
the slots casino yes or no
that's a good question i don't know but
i can certainly find out um i'm
quite friendly with the chair of the
mass gaming commission um we used to
have the same job in massachusetts
she was the successor general counsel
the mass lottery to me so
i have no problem calling her and asking
her terrific
thank you
any further questions for challenge
uh once more any any further questions
for charlie on the
lottery revenues okay
okay charlie thanks for coming in again
of course thank you mr chairman members
of the committee um thank you so much
chris
major is anybody as cathy labonte here
she is and just bring her into the
meeting
and um if it helps i can pull up their
presentation from last week
it was just two pages you can see the
various revenue sources
that go into the numbers that would help
okay one moment
so it it was just a two-page
presentation and i'll just have it on
page two which is the 21 22 and 23
um revenue estimates and kathy
you can just remind the committee of
the various revenue sources and then
they may have questions as a result
of that
okay i was trying to
[Music]
there we go now you can see me okay um
remind you of the different revenue
types go down through the list
is is that what you would like me to do
this morning
i believe so kathy um on on the schedule
you provided the committee last week you
you know you listed out like the
licenses the agent fees
just to remind the committee of what
some of those might be
okay now that they've had a week to
think about it
okay um so we have our licenses which is
our
biggest part of unrestricted revenues
our concord agent fees which is the one
dollar
fee per license type that is sold here
in our concord
office miscellaneous sales and
income is kind of a melting pot
of revenues that does not have fall into
any other category
and as i stated last week and i'll
restate the biggest deposit
into that fund is the internal
administrative charge that we charge for
overhead on all of our dedicated
accounts here at the department
and that is approximately 250 to 300
000 per year the ohrv
license agent fees is the same as the
concrete agent fees only that's the oh
the
fee charge for ohrv registrations and
for this current fiscal year that just
went up to four dollars per registration
license agent fines and penalties those
funds are submitted by license agents
that are late in submitting their
monthly
um monthly reports along with their
monthly remittances they have until the
14th of the month
to submit those they are allowed to
uh request one waiver per year
and we are allowed to find them if uh of
course with covid we did
allow a lot of people we were very very
lenient
for a lot of people interest on savings
deposits
i made a significant adjustment to our
current fiscal year 21 budgeted on that
because our interest revenues have taken
a considerable nosedives like all of
ours
sale on surplus property are those
funds that we receive for equipment that
we send over to
surplus that subsequently gets sold to
the public
sale of surplus vehicles same thing only
that is specific to all fish and game
vehicles that get
sold after we surplus them federal
recoveries and direct costs that is the
uh another large pot of funding
and that is actually the indirect cost
that is charged on all of our federal
grants
which all of our federal grants is
approximately
seven to ten million dollars per year
and it's an overhead charge
that we are able to charge for the cost
of
personnel and benefits
that is overhead
game management transfers let me
read that one to you because that one's
a little bit
more detailed um so initially
all license revenues are deposited into
that first pot of money 5221
but after monthly reconciliations ten
dollars
from the sale of each turkey bear and
waterfowl
license sold and each moose application
and subsequent permit when drawn are
deposited
into the dedicated game management
account
and all funds remaining are transferred
into this unrestricted
game management account
and the ohrv and marine unrefunded road
toll
per the rsas that i notate below
260 colon 60 and 260 colon 61
in statute those are transferred from
the department of safety into the
unrestricted fish and game fund
is that helpful questions the first one
is
representative romney yeah uh thank you
come on thank you um so
let's talk about the transfers on the uh
rotols
so maureen i kind of understand that
they probably have the pumps right by
the water and they know that they are
the pumps uh well again someone would
have with a boat that has a trailer they
may fill up their tank uh
at a regular gas station how do they
know
how do they and the same thing with the
off-road vehicle
how do they know that the gasoline is
being sold
for that use to be actually what
what that is is we here at fish and game
are responsible for
sending the department of safety road
toll bureau
the annual report of all registrations
sold for ohrv and they
take that figure say it's 85 000
registrations a year they take that
figure and they
plug it into a formula on their side
based on unrefunded fuel
and that's how they come up with that
figure
okay because my understanding is that
there is if if you have a boat and you
fill
and you for your tan let's say you fill
your tank up
uh you can the individual can apply for
a refund of the tax part right
that's the right absolutely right the
same thing with an off-road vehicle
they can they can a lot of people don't
so that's the um that's the unrun
refunded part of this correct that is
correct
right so all right uh
i just wasn't sure how that all worked
and you say there's some kind of a
formula that i use to
calculate how much you go back on on
both
on both parts of money it's a formula
used for
the amount of ohrv registrations that
are registered
annually and the amount of boats that
are registered now boat registrations of
course run through the department of
safety so that's all done
internally and for the number of ohrv
registrations that's a figure that we
actually send over to them on an annual
basis
okay thank you you're welcome that's a
lot of money
it is okay representative
elmy thank you mr chairman
i'd just like to comment on the last one
maybe we'd like to find out what that
formula is and whether they
update it every now and then but
um i have a question
about the the
the fact i think you have more money in
the sub funds
the dedicated funds on especially the
the the game licenses other than moose
on i believe all have been merged into
one fund
there's a fund for there's a license for
a turkey there's a license
for uh a partridge i think there's a
license for all sorts of
of of smaller game
and deer and such and
i think they've all been merged into the
same since they're improving the habitat
for for one animal they're usually
improving it for
others as well and they use them for
that purpose as i
recall but i i wonder for
us to try to understand the fission game
revenues if we really don't need to have
some kind
of understanding of how much is in
those dedicated funds
i have that list right here in front of
me
thank you i
i wanted to be completely prepared for
all of your questions today
um and you are absolutely right about
these smaller funds
many years ago we had a waterfowl a
turkey and a
bear and moose account all separate
and it did not make sense to have all
those separate accounts
they were merged into what we call now
the game management account
so we have right now on the books
16 dedicated accounts and you're asking
specifically
for the game management account i have
the balance that was brought
forward into fiscal year 21
and that would have been 1.6 million
dollars
thank you i know i know this is in our
dedicated
fund what i call a telephone book
enormous compilation um
but what are what's the total for all of
the dedicated accounts
and how how much comes in from the feds
oh i i don't well total federal dollars
uh really varies on an annual basis
it averages seven to ten million a year
the unobligated balance that came
forward
into fiscal year 21 which means when we
close the books
june 30th of 2020
in our dedicated accounts meaning
you know not these funds cannot be used
in the unrestricted fiction game fund
with 7.2 million
thank you so in fact we're looking at
about
half of of the expenses that are in
fees i i would like to go on and
i would like to go on and say that 1.3
million of that was ohrv
and as we know um ohrv
is used for certainly law enforcement
and when um the ohrv funds come in
approximately
72 to 75 percent of those funds get
transferred over to dncr
thank you you're welcome any further
questions from the committee
stand none cathy thank you for your
presentation
well thank you mr chairman and members
of the committee
donna call is there any chance she might
be
on the line he is not yet represent
major i had reached out to
um dana and monica and asked them to
join the call a little bit early um
about 10 minutes earlier of their
schedule time so we're still 20 minutes
ahead of what i'd asked them to do
um based on reps of almi's question
about the
department of safety and their
calculation for the unr unrefunded tolls
i did send a question over to steve
lavoy and scott breyer to
get a response from them on that
okay multitasking as we're working here
today
except some of my emails aren't going
out
i can reach out to dana and monica again
with an email
and see if they could join sooner but
unless there's something the committee
needs to talk about at this moment
i don't know if you want to take a break
for a few minutes or
any questions or comments from the
committee
if you don't we will take a break until
25 after uh norm
representative schamberg here yes are we
exacting any bills tomorrow or are we
just having hearings
tomorrow i talked to susan
and we plan on executing
okay all right i just wanna make sure i
heard's right and will that be
after the hearings or be sometime during
if there's time between hearing
then we will hopefully be able to
execute a bill
too okay i won't have any time for the
exact at the end of the last hearing
okay thank you sir but there's only
there's only four bills that
uh candidates for liking tomorrow
and i can go through those right now and
those are bills that uh
as a result of the republican caucus
another kind of caucus
pretty close that would be house bill
15. house bill 281
house bill 353 i mean 33
53 yeah 353
house bill 583
543 and 533 is an early bill and we need
to get that out tomorrow
so the one two three four bills
thank you chairman and it was
15 281 353
let me hospital 15.
281 353
and 533 thank you
uh norm yes um i've been taking notes
and i
keep going back to eddie's comments
about how much covit is going to
affect these revenues um but it seems
like we have some revenues that we don't
really think kova is going to affect
very much
we have others like meals and rooms
where there might be a very great effect
and make might make sense going forward
to kind of break those
out right
you've been on this before and what we
usually end up
doing is that we
take care of the easy revenues first
those that such as tom refers to
that we're pretty confident don't very
much
and we have great confidence in the
agencies
and we don't feel that clove is
and we'll have to identify those that we
feel covert
isn't going to affect very much
this is why we need to get
somebody from hhs come before the
committee
and so we can question them relative to
where is this covet going do we see
light at the end of the tunnel is it
going to get worse is it going to get
better is it going to reoccur again
we need the best estimates on that
we don't do th if we don't do that with
hhs we're really not doing our job
i agree um any further
comments before we take a break well
you know if we could get the link uh mr
chairman to that two-hour
meeting with of course
chris is going to send that link to us
okay i'd be happy to
to look at it this weekend and see
whether there's a section that's
particularly
relevant not only you whoever else will
do that
and it will help the committee as a
whole it would be
two hours is a long time and
if the
the new people are
right at the same point as we are on
this covert so
i invite them to do the same
right major yes chris
um dana call is on the line now
so she could meet with the committee now
if you're ready
that would be fine and i'll reach out to
monica as well and
maybe she can join in the middle of the
conversation
uh monica's a treasurer and she would be
talking to you about abandoned property
if there were any questions
so if there weren't any questions then
she's not needed but i'll reach out to
her
does dana need to have the screen
share um i don't know what she'd have to
tell us
uh can you hear me now yes we can dana
do you have anything you want to share
on a screen dana
no i'm i'm just available for questions
i don't have anything to present today
the um can you put up
their handout from the last
and they're going to concentrate on the
so-called
other revenues
correct i went through this presentation
last time we met so i can follow up with
any additional questions
okay so i've got it on page three of the
presentation
um that just talks about kind of an
overview of the different
other revenue that's tracked and
collected by das and by other agencies
okay
let me pull out the participant list
see all right representative
software you have questions
represented southwest yeah i apologize
my hand was up from before okay uh
representative brown yeah this is
actually for chris
um what what percent i don't have
the sheets in front of me but what
percent we're hearing from uh
from uh about abandoned property because
it's a it's a large number compared to
the rest
what percentage of the total is
abandoned property
on the other yeah i think slide six has
a good depiction
of that so so i'm on slide six now and
you can see abandoned properties
um estimated to be about 17.3 million
in 21 16.8 million and 22
and 18.4 million and 23.
but when we look at the total for uh
okay i'm sorry okay
so the total the total in the other
category
you know is 64. 8 million
of that 17.3 would be from abandoned
property in 2021
right and that's why we're breaking it
out just to
make sure we get that one understand
that that large number
compared to the rest of these
miscellaneous revenues there's about
what 200
of dedicated
funds there
is that the right number i think dana
said something like 140 now
but it has been up closer to 200 in past
years
okay dana you can correct me
yeah they're revenue sources in our
financial system
so they may or may not be dedicated but
they are
various revenue sources collected by the
agencies
and that whole 140 represents that 26.7
million
yes yeah and then
the others three are the major items
reimbursement indirect costs
post-retirement benefits recovery
and abandoned property correct those are
the top
three within the entire category of
other
uh representative oh no
i i didn't lower my hand i'm sorry okay
representative yuri
jordan i gotta find the thing
because anyway uh chris could you please
share my email address
uh i've got a constituent with an issue
and
jordan i can't hear you
jordan can you speak up
how's this better better yeah
chris could you please share my email
address uh so that i can
contact her directly i have a
constituent with an issue regarding
unclaimed property and a small thing she
should be aware of
thank you
represent elmi
thank you mr chairman on i just wanted
to
ask there are a number of these that
in the other category that are
on our boards gas fitter fees
things like that that are in the larger
part of the
other category are those lapses
is that the way that one works lapse at
the end of the year
of what the board hasn't had to spend
um this would be just on the revenue
side so
it would be any revenue they collected
that would support
the expenditure of that agency
so it doesn't it this particular rev
these particular revenue sources here
are unrestricted revenues that support
general fund spending as a whole
uh so if they if they
collect what they planned to collect
we're in good shape if they collect less
than they planned
then our hope is that another revenue
source comes in higher
and net net the total category comes
within plan
does that answer your question yeah my
question
comes from on in the past we were
looking at
the board of electricians which had been
absorbed
into safety at a time when we had a very
long-term commissioner
and on plumbers
on the idea was that electricians should
should go with plumbers the electricians
were very
upset about this partly because uh some
of their expenses were
of their fees were being used for things
that belonged to all of safety and not
to them
and they eventually got out of there but
um do you
do you when they're they're within
another agency
and they aren't completely uh within the
what that agency is doing do you look at
how these expenses go on
how they are using their expenses or
does anybody do that
we do not do that here in central
accounting but i'm
i'm sure that the department of safety
would have more
information on that it's one of their
revenue sources
so i would i would not speak for them
any further questions on the committee
um chris is monika
have you been able to contact her yet um
i haven't been able to get in touch with
her yet
but again the committee is meeting a
little bit sooner than i had originally
told her
okay so she
she may get on in by 11 20 because dana
was able to but i don't know
um and if there's any specific questions
um
for her that the committee doesn't want
to stay on the call until
she gets on like i can share those with
her and
bring back to the committee we can wait
until she gets on
um it's however you want to proceed
represent major
like she may be on in the next five or
ten minutes oh wait
okay um and and if i might represent
over you would just like me to get you
the abandoned property information and
send it to your email
yeah i've got a constituent uh that uh
had a
um interesting conversation with
people on the phone um and i wanted to
relay that
okay yeah so i'll get you the treasurer
and then the um director of abandoned
properties
email addresses and i'll send them to
you okay fine thank you
and what we're looking at on the screen
now is some of the other
unrestricted revenues
one you see the labor transfer in the
middle of the page
so if i can yes highlight it yeah so
that's an example of an agency that's
uh has a dedicated funding mechanism
currently
so all the fees that they collect go
into a a a
dedicated fund they pay their expenses
from that so that the legislature
appropriates them
in a budget and it's paid through that
fund and at the end of the year
they transfer any balance that's
remaining to the general fund so that's
a it's a revenue transfer
into other category so that's
one example um i think kind of relates
to what represent volume was asking
about like the gas fitters
gas fitters i think is set in statute so
that they're
they're a generally funded board so all
their fees go into the general fund and
then they are funded through the general
fund
and the reviews that you would have for
those types of agencies
um by the legislature would be
essentially be during this budget
process so if there's any specific
questions on
a specific fund and how it's being used
to pay for
activities with an agency you know
that's a time that sometimes the
finance committee will will have that
discussion with the agencies and
sometimes as a result of that you might
see language added to house bill 2 to
address some of those concerns
um so i would suggest that if there's
members of of
house ways and means or any other
committee that
has a concern about an activity that's
funded through the budget that is in
a debt using a dedicated or restricted
fund
share that with your finance um members
and and
they can maybe address that as part of
the the
budget preparation process
in addition our office will sometimes do
audits of these various entities
um we do performance audits and
financial audits performance audits are
driven by
the legislative performance audit
oversight committee um
looking more at like your efficiency
effectiveness type of issues and then
obviously the financial audits look at
the finances so there's a those are two
ways that
somebody outside the agency might look
at some of these entities
the uh there's one line there the
indigent
representation yep uh
fy 2020 actual was 1895
does this mean that it was funded
and this is the excess over that or
however so that's basically a recovery
of judicial counsel okay um expenses so
when they when they pay
um or they pay for the services that are
provided for those individuals that
can't afford an attorney or the services
around that
um they do there's a process within
administrative services to look at
individuals to see if they
could reimburse the state for some
portion of that money
on their defense or on their case um
so that's what that represents and
that's why it's
fairly difficult i think to to know
exactly what they're going to get from
year to year because it's it's uh
really dependent on what they can
recover that's a fairly large amount
yeah 1.8 million oh chris i was just
going to add
that's a great explanation and it's done
through our costa collections division
here and admin services
but they did have some recent
legislative changes that i think
restricted the amount that i shouldn't
use the term restricted but
um we we expect to collect less because
of some recent changes in legislation so
that is
um commissioner arlinghaus had given me
a lower estimate for that line item
going forward
thank you dana and i'm sorry i should
have let dana respond to that
no i think that was a great response
okay uh representative brownie
i was going to ask this question but
since we have time if you go to the
aircraft operations fees
uh i guess it would be dana
years ago we we had a bill that we
actually
lowered the fees to encourage more
planes to be based in new hampshire but
does that line
also include the fuel tax that we
collect
from both the prop plains and jet a
fuel that's used i
would expect not i can check with the
department of transportation
unless chris knows but we since we've
identified that particular revenue
source
just for aircraft operator fees i would
expect there wouldn't be other funds
commingled in that line
so those are the those are the aircraft
registration fees to
be based to have your plane uh based
in new hampshire correct it's like car
registration but it's an airplane
registration
correct yes yeah thank you
okay is moniker of us yet
she's not
representative major could i on
on add something to the dedicated fund
discussion
yes thank you on i was
on the division in finance many many
years ago
which was supposed to be dealing with
these things and
i understand that they're still they pay
very little attention to the dedicated
funds because they're concentrated on
the
general fund and the education trust
fund
and that is why over the i worked over
the years on dedicated
fund uh oversight
for a long time and we now have a
dedicated
fund joint committee with the senate
which is doing
five-year cycle uh reviews of all of the
dedicated funds
by agency and on we have in the past
on uh found saying
things the the uh office for
professional licensure and certification
had came and asked us for a uh
told us that they they because we were
talking with them they went
and asked for a performance audit which
is coming to them shortly and if anybody
does have
uh questions about dedicated funds i
think
uh we are doing a five-year cycle but we
do it uh representative major i think
he's going to chair again
uh i think i'm going to be clerk again
we also take things out of order when
we've got questions that have come up
so that we can look at particular
dedicated funds and see
we we look at how much money uh
they have accumulated that they aren't
using
uh that's been a problem what used to be
a problem in some of them
we look at whether they've got too
little money to do what they're supposed
to be doing or they're doing the same
thing as something else
on the the funds have been getting
a lot more regularized over this
long period in which we've been looking
at them
that'll make tomorrow easier when we
discuss
house bill 134 which is repealing the
dedicated dedicated funds
the treasurer is on the line now and
she'll be promoted into the call
okay great um and just a follow up with
the dedicated funds
that document is produced by
department of administrative services
and is available on their website so you
can see the
uh as representative referred to it as
the phone book
electronically on on department of
administrative services website and
you'll see all the dedicated
funds that are established in the state
um it does provide the statutory
reference so if you're
curious as to you know how it's set up
and what the law is saying
and to the comment about the um finance
committee
maybe not looking as much at the
dedicated funds as they do the general
fund and the education trust fund as
well as
fish and game and and highway funds
unrestricted
um that's a true statement partly
because a lot of the
dedicated funds provide authority to
the commissioner or a commission or
group to
appropriate and spend the money in those
dedicated funds
so so the legislature through the
legislation has decided that
you know the money should be available
for a certain purpose and and
they come forward and present it in
their budget and
they may have a language that allows
them to if they have more revenue than
they expected to just go ahead and
budget that for the activity um
so so that kind of led to the purpose i
think of the
the commission that she was talking
about just a moment ago
to review the dedicated funds to make
sure they were being used
the way that the legislature intended uh
make sure that
you know over time things haven't
changed where the funds maybe need to be
used differently
and if that was the case then a
legislation could be introduced um to
reflect what the use of the funds should
be going forward and then
if the fund wasn't being used to repeal
it
and clean it up a little bit and so when
you look at the dedicated fund report
you'll see that there's some they're all
numbered starting one and they go up to
like 350 now somewhere in that range
but you'll see you know some numbers are
repealed um
purposely the numbers aren't reused you
just keep adding to the end as you're
creating new funds so
i think partly for historical reason and
not to confuse the
any any history that might be traced
so based on that um and now that
monica's in the meeting
um i'll i'll be quiet and if there's any
questions you have specific to abandoned
property or anything else the treasurer
does with interest in surplus or any
other
functions i'm sure she'd be happy to
discuss that with you
does she have a screen that she wants to
share with us
monica do you have anything you want to
share or you're just going to respond to
questions from the committee
yes uh good morning good morning
everyone and um
mr chairman thanks again for for the
invitation to be here
i i don't have anything to to present to
you today i'll be happy to answer any
questions you have
um i'm very sorry i just i just joined
the meeting so um
um i had a different commitment um but
uh but if you wanna uh
if you i know you're reviewing the
estimates that we provided
um what i can briefly say i think um two
weeks ago when i when i was
um and this meeting um meeting
um with with all of you um you know i
mentioned that the
estimates that we provide are really
based on
a 10-year average that we calculate um
so that's so those are the numbers that
you know this this
methodology that we use uh 10-year
average produces
um and so um when we calculate this
estimate it really is
um i mentioned i mentioned in the past
so
after three years when we we were unable
to return
um funds to to the rightful owners
um then we have this property that we're
able to estee to the counties
and the general fund and so we use
um the the components of the calculation
that i
share with you two weeks ago um
you know we use those components are
more consistent year
year things that we know um the ca the
the
property that is reported to us an
average of
um what we pay each you know
during the last 10 years an average of
what we pay
and so the only component that is
difficult to estimate is
is the value of um the pres
the amount of proceeds that we're going
to receive when we sell securities
so that's really the only one that
really will perhaps
drive the number that we provide
either higher or lower depending on you
know how
the fair market value of those
securities is going to be at the time
that we um that we sell those securities
so that really is a foundation how we
come up with those numbers
the the so that's what we have
and then once we start selling
securities which will start
um i will say in about a month that's
when we start that process
we don't typically recalculate the
estimate because we really
still don't have any changes so it's
really until june when we
we when we might have a better idea if
the number that we estimated
is going to change um so
so so that's that's really what i can
share with you
i'll be happy to answer any questions
that that you may have
um represent romney
oh again i i forgot to lower my hand
from before
i'm sorry um let me ask you a question
moniker where we have
a pandemic going on and
we have the death rate
in new hampshire we're a lot better off
than other states
but i would assume there'd be more
abandoned property
down the road because of the pandemic
have you accounted for for this
yeah that is a great question i think
um you know
you know when we when we when we met
with with the committee
uh two weeks ago we we kind of have an
idea of
some of the trends that might change the
amount of property that we will get
uh or how the industry might change
um you know during the next few years
but the pandemic is not one of them so i
think it will be
um you know kind of a similar effort
depending on how soon
holders report to us the type of
property perhaps that will drive
the property reported but some of the
changes that we also make in
the way we um you know we now um you
know claimants can
can claim their funds so
there's some changes that could occur
the other way so we may get more funds
reported to us
but then we may have more individuals
claiming property since they have more
access to computers in their home
and and so they're able to search for
property
uh more than than others so it's a great
question so i think to
answer you your question is that has not
been
uh included in this estimate um this
estimate is really
strictly based on the information that
we've
that we have during that has occurred
over the last 10 years uh based on the
property that has been reported to us
three years ago um and and so that's
that's what we're presenting today
it is really a better estimate i think
um
just because we're consistent with the
methodology and i think most of the
times
um it doesn't change that much it did
change last year again because of the
unknown variable
of securities how this amer the fair
market value of those securities is
going to change
that really is what could drive um
a significant change if the market were
to change
right now it doesn't appear that it's
happening um you know we could have some
adjustments some
some um corrections in the capital
market in the coming months but
it is it's it wouldn't be um it's not
anticipated to be a a
right now of course we don't know um we
can't time the market and all of that
but uh
it's not anticipated to be a very big
adjustment like we
the one we had last year as a result of
the pandemic
okay representative thank you mr
chairman
monica i think i started on this
question last time but
the issue of when securities are sold
or maybe we discussed it before on
there are at least some brokerages that
in order to
avoid timing the market and losing
on sell or buy
over a longer period of time and i
wonder
if the selling process is
complicated enough that you couldn't
institute something like that
it's right now if we get the wrong day
all these people lose and if we get a
beautiful day they win
right no in and that is a great question
i actually when i had an opportunity to
to speak to mr mcnasty about this
um you know we just explore your
question your exact question and
and so um he reminded me of um
really how this process uh works it's
not a one-day transaction it doesn't
happen
you know in one day it really the
process and this
is the custodian that does it for us
they start um selling
um i think like i think they start
around march time and
it takes a couple of months it takes a
few months to um
to really do that so they start selling
the start
their stun um you know that process and
so for us when we receive the proceeds
we receive the proceeds
um i think sometime in may when we start
receiving some payments
from that from those um you know from
those sales
and um so it is not it doesn't happen in
one day it does happen over time
um so so
it was last year it really was during
those
bad months because as you know the
markets recovered
in may we were back you know they were
back to normal in may
um june the market was up again so it
really was
just a very bad timing uh
last year so again unless we have the
same
the same bad time in this year
which i don't anticipate um i hope i
don't have to come back to you and say
i'm so sorry about this
for my back my bad estimates um
but we really don't anticipate it so it
really is a process that takes
longer and we couldn't we couldn't sell
every month like it really we
really need to wait until this property
meets that period of
um you know meets the requirement okay
we haven't returned this funds
um and so securities was for one year so
we need to hold those securities for
that
whole period the whole one-year period
and all for us to be able to sell it so
um the way we the way it is established
today uh we we couldn't start selling
you know months of the month we will
have to probably change
our process significantly to to do
something like that
any further questions of monica
represent major yes just for the
committee's
um just for information for the
committee monica that
the transfer occurs in june related to
abandoned property revenue correct
that is correct so that that it's it's
an end of the year
um activity that occurs so just so the
committee knows there's no
monthly or quarterly estimates go along
with this it's it's
um the treasurer is trying to estimate
for for year end
what they think they might transfer and
i think what monica's um
alluded to is that you know there could
be factors between now and june that
um may impact the estimate to some
extent
exactly and and so that's the reason why
our our estimates really don't change
we have our best estimate but there's
really not a lot we can change
from now until the actual calculation
happens and
um it's just because we do have to wait
for
for for the you know to meet the the
requirements of the property
and that's what we we try to calculate
it as soon as we can
so it does happen um some you know
mid-june so we're able to uh
you know um so we're able to submit all
of the funding
um the this treatment revenue to the
general fund
before the end of the year before june
30. so
um i know administrative services
they're asking us about
you you do you you know the beginning of
june is do you still expect
the amount coming on time and we always
say yes but
what we know this you know that
anticipation of our revenue
um expected before the end of the year
any further comments or questions from
the committee
monica thank you again
my pleasure thanks again for the
invitation how could you answer any
questions
if you have any after this okay
thank you um for the committee
we're thrilled of our revenues for this
morning
and remind you that we have our public
hearings
seven bills tomorrow and we're going to
try to
uh an exact floor bills that we had
heard
previously i had sent
an email an email out to the
republican members about the caucus
today at four if you didn't get that
email
would you either call me or
send me an email so i can resend the
link to you
does anybody else have any other
comments before
we close mr chairman i'd just
like to let you know that uh the
democratic caucus is meeting on saturday
afternoons now it seems to be the best
time for everybody
oh saturday afternoon wow
good for you
or whatever
representative army i mean uh bromley
so uh you said that uh tomorrow is still
up in the air a little bit
uh but how are you gonna you're gonna
communicate if it's gonna be a total
uh virtual meeting and not in person is
that it or
are you are you going making the call
right now that
um as at this point
it's a hybrid meeting
because i do not have confirmation
otherwise is that a firm is that
is that going to potentially change uh
and if it does if it changes
we'll send out an uh an email to the
full committee
all right so the committee should be
looking for an email um
okay thank you personally i would like
to have it changed but
uh so
still if it doesn't change i will be
there i hope
not many others will be
but and i'll try to be as loud as i can
all right anything else then for the
republicans we're going to be
meeting at four and i guess we also have
another caucus at six right
yeah okay caucus
the whole day all right
thank you everybody thank you
thank